how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the mcu and today
is a special
day as we have an exclusive channel
report about
hercules coming to the marvel cinematic
universe
now at this point in time there's
actually been several reports stating
that hercules is going to be making his
way to the mcu
and it could be as early on as phase 4.
based off of all of the reports it does
seem like marvel studios has big plans
for hercules and in this video we have
the exclusive about what they're
thinking
so we'll break down this new exclusive
report in this video and talk about when
we can expect to see hercules make his
marvel cinematic universe debut
if you're new be sure to subscribe so
you can stay up to date on all the
latest
mcu news and big congratulations to
youtube
user garbage can 57 for being the winner
of the scarlet witch
funko pop just email me in the email in
my description and we'll get you your
funko pop
and for this week's giveaway it's going
to be a gambit funko pop so all you have
to do to enter subscribe
like the video and leave a comment down
below so today's exclusive report comes
from
inside scooper and personal friend mikey
sutton
mikey has leaked a lot of things over
the years most of which has ended up
coming true and today he has an
exclusive report about hercules in the
marvel cinematic universe
the future of the mcu can often be seen
in the past in december of 2019
mikey sutton scooped that hercules would
be headed to the mcu
hercules was being discussed for disney
plus perhaps part of a journey into
mystery show
but as usual plans evolve and now talks
are veering towards his
own disney plus tv series one that is
again
rooted in the history of marvel comics
the 1982
hercules miniseries written and
illustrated by bob layton
reads like a blueprint of the mcu the
fast-paced mix of humor and adventure
enveloped in a cosmic rapping of vintage
star wars like
good times was so ahead of its time
echoing the mcu work of james gunn and
taikowatiti decades
later so it's no surprise that marvel
studios is looking at incorporating
elements of this book for its potential
hercules show
but whether or not it will be adapted or
not remains to be seen
now in the original hercules comic
hercules hilariously gets galactus
drunk who was finally shown minus the
helmet such goofball irreverence is
straight out of the james gunn slash
taikawatiti playbook but
it'll be up to marvel studios and the
future showrunner to see how far it will
go
now we're going to further break down
this report but for the second part of
this report head over to the youtube
channel lords of the long box to see who
else might be appearing in the series
and i'll link them at the end of this
video and down below as well
so it seems like things are going quite
nicely for hercules to get his own
series as marvel studios and disney are
talking about developing a show for him
right now now hercules will make for a
very fine addition to the marvel
cinematic universe
especially if he's going to interact
with characters such as thor and
star-lord from the guardians of the
galaxy and there have
been reports in the past stating that we
could see him before his appearance in
his very own disney plush show
and this would kind of stick true to
what marvel seemingly does
introducing characters before they get
their very own show
or movie such as spider-man and black
panther were introduced in captain
america civil war and both went on to
have
very successful solo films now as far as
the earliest that we could see
hercules enter the marvel cinematic
universe goes mikey did report that
hercules is coming
back in 2019 and then recently there was
a report by
cinemablend stating that we could be
getting hercules sooner than later
their report said that sources have told
them that hercules is coming to the mcu
sooner than later now at the time they
said that it was unclear whether or not
this was going to be a supporting role
in a current project or
a lead role in his own project now it
was once rumored that hercules could
appear in marvel's eternals
but since then the rumor has been put to
doubt now if you don't know anything
about hercules he's an
olympian it's basically the greek
mythology hercules that is very well
known
so he is a god he's a god just like
thor so although there are plenty of
options for projects that hercules could
show up in for phase 4
it would make the most sense that he
would appear in thor love and thunder
and then after his mcu debut in thor
love and thunder
then they could lead into his very own
disney plus show such as mikey
is reporting now one of the coolest
things about this report from mikey is
that he says
that hercules in the mcu is going to be
rooted based off of the 1982
hercules miniseries which is described
as a fast-paced
mix of humor and adventure enveloped in
a cosmic rapping of vintage
star wars like good times and this is
pretty much what they've been building
thor
up to be and we know that thor is going
to dive into the cosmos a little bit in
thor love and thunder but it seems like
marvel's plans for hercules is to really
dive into the cosmos and dive into space
with his stories and based off of this
report it looks like we're going to get
something very similar to
thor ragnarok and the guardians of the
galaxy
this is something that marvel has
recently found with thor ragnarok that
they do
very very well and the guardians of the
galaxy have nailed the humor and
seriousness of adventure
since guardians vol 1. so as far as what
to expect from hercules we're pretty
much going to see a character that's
very similar to thor
and could eventually and possibly even
go on to take
thor's spot in the new avengers
unfortunately it's been rumored for a
while that chris hemsworth might be done
as thor after thor love and thunder it's
speculated that that may be why they're
bringing in jane foster to become
the new thor but even if they don't
bring in a new thor and chris hemsworth
stays which we all want to happen
thor and hercules have a very long
history of fighting together
side by side in the comics these two
have a hilarious partnership and you can
only imagine what it would be like in
the mcu
you would essentially have two best
friends that are pretty much
just like each other so just imagine if
thor had a twin
and they were best friends that's what
we're in for so very much
thor ragnarok vibes pretty much times
two
and then there's the introduction of
olympus now thor and hercules do have
very similar stories
thor was banished to earth without
mjolnir in the mcu
and hercules gets banished from olympus
by zeus
as well but eventually he is able to
return
so when hercules finally does make his
debut there are going to be other
godlike characters and
beans in the mcu and this is the route
that marvel seems to be taking lately
introducing the eternals who are godlike
beings themselves and the celestials in
the eternals as well
and depending on what we see in the
eternals what route they decide to take
the celestial god beings they could even
be responsible for
creating the olympian such as they
created the eternals and
they created the deviants and not to
mention that marvel studios has been
wanting to introduce the cosmic entities
to the mcu in fact we almost saw
the living tribunal in avengers infinity
war
but ultimately marvel decided that
introducing a cosmic entity
right now was a little bit too early and
may confuse people and overwhelm them
but kevin feige has stated several times
that the future of the mcu is a cosmic
future and we can clearly see which
direction that marvel studios wants to
take the mcu
the future of the mcu is going to be
divided into two different teams one is
going to be the ground team that fights
on earth and takes care of the villains
on earth and then we're going to have
the cosmic team that's going to fight in
space
characters such as captain marvel the
guardians of the galaxy and now it seems
like
hercules are going to be a part of that
team and if we're lucky perhaps they'll
even bring in beta ray bill
as well but in the meantime let me know
what you think about hercules getting
his very own disney plush show and
possibly making his mcu debut in thor
love and thunder
what would you think if we had two gods
who were hilarious both interacting and
fighting with each other
let me know all of your thoughts in the
comments down below don't forget to like
this video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on all the latest
marvel cinematic universe news for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof